from the new york post it says a strict
new measure that essentially bans
abortion in texas went into effect at
midnight despite protests and lawsuits
against the harsh mandate
uh this is the new york post language
anyway the harsh mandate the law
prohibits women from getting an abortion
after a fetal heartbeat can be detected
and gives citizens the right to take
legal action against doctors or anyone
else who helps a woman terminate a
pregnancy most women who get an abortion
in the lone star state are at least six
weeks pregnant and will now be unable to
receive the procedure according to
planned parenthood and whole women's
health the texas bill differs from other
similar heartbeat laws nationwide
because it bars authorities from
enforcing the ban
and allows anyone else to take legal
action
under the measure anyone who
successfully sues a doctor or accomplice
would be entitled to at least ten
thousand dollars which critics claim
will flood the courts with opportunistic
legal cases
and yes people who are opportunistically
trying to stop babies from being killed
very very opportunistic of them the
wide-ranging provision allows suits
against patients nurses counselors or
even someone who drove
a patient to an appointment uh so that's
the law that went into effect there was
a there was a mad dash by the
pro-abortion pro-death pro-baby killing
side to stop it and they weren't able to
and now the left is
absolutely panicking over this as you
can imagine the aclu
which is supposed to be the civil
liberties institute they're supposed to
stand for liberty and you would think
the most
fundamental and basic liberty is is is
that to
to live the right to life
because if you don't have the right to
life the ability to live then then all
of your other rights would seem to be
sort of null and void
but they're very pro-baby-killing and so
they sent out a whole series of tweets
um
they said the supreme court has not
responded to our emergency request to
block texas's radical new six-week
abortion ban the law now takes effect
access to almost all abortion has just
been cut off for millions of people the
impact will be immediate and devastating
uh and that that's these are the words
i've seen the left using in response to
this bill
which is expected devastating
tragic
unjust
infuriating
nancy pelosi called the law a
catastrophe a catastrophe catastrophic
because because
fewer babies will be killed that's what
they're upset about
it's catastrophic
that now we're going to allow
more children to live
corey bush
sent out this tweet she says i'm
thinking about the black brown low
income queer and young folks in texas
the folks this abortion healthcare bill
uh healthcare ban will
disproportionately harm
wealthy white folks will have the means
to access abortion our communities won't
now i'm not sure how uh
an abortion ban will disproportionately
affect uh quote unquote queer folks i
don't know how that how that works
exactly
but this is the only
tune that corey bush knows and so she
just hums it every single time no matter
what the issue is
it's always going to be well this
disproportionately impacts
these uh these people
uh now does it in disproportionately
impact the black community
in a sense yeah but what is the
disproportionate impact
because there is a because
a disproportionate number of black
children are aborted that's true
and so now the dis proportionate impact
is that more black people will be
allowed to live
okay there will be more black people in
texas now than there would be without
this bill this bill
will will have the direct and immediate
effect
of ensuring among other things along
with saving so many other babies
but since she brings up these protected
classes
it will also have the immediate effect
of ensuring that more black people will
live in texas
and cory bush as a black woman is is
opposed to that
whichever if you're opposed to it then
come out and say it
just come out and say it i i
i i want these black children who are
going to live now i think they should be
dead i think that they should not be
allowed to continue existing
come out and say it if that's your
opinion because that is your opinion
um
now is is this law in texas is it in
keeping with roe v wade
supreme court's going to weigh in on
that
and i don't have a whole lot of
confidence in what their decision is
going to be
i have confidence in maybe
two of the uh of the justices on the
supreme court thomas and alito when it
comes to this issue on the rest i don't
i don't know
but does it violate roe v wade
my answer is who cares
i don't care if it does
rho is imaginary
okay
they located the right to abortion
in invisible ink in the constitution
or they may as well have
the roe v wade decision may as well have
said well a uh
a fairy came into our chambers
and sprinkled pixie dust
on the constitution
and invisible words
suddenly were made apparent that said
you have a right to an abortion they
that may as well have been the decision
because it is that absurd
has no basis in reality whatsoever
again they they they located
the right to abortion constitutionally
within
the constitutional right to privacy
which is not a constitutional right so
there's nothing in the constitution that
says right to privacy
and that's what they based the right to
abortion in
and even that's not in there so this is
the right to abortion is is two degrees
removed from the constitution
it's grounded in constitutional language
that does not exist itself
so it's a horrible decision that even if
you're an honest pro-abortion person
which is a category of people that i'm
not sure actually exists
just as the right to abortion doesn't
exist but if you were then
you even you should say yeah i think
that abortion is good or whatever i'm in
favor of it but
uh there's no right to it in the
constitution
a couple other points here
as we see the left panicking over this
bill in texas now that more children
will be allowed to live
um
i've got to make this point again for
the millionth time but it's so important
because what we're hearing over and over
again
and what you'll continue to hear is that
this bill is an attack it's an assault
on reproductive rights
i have to continue to emphasize that
it's not an assault on reproductive
rights
because because
this has nothing to do with reproduction
abortion has absolutely nothing to do
with reproduction
reproduction is a separate issue
do i think that women have reproductive
rights
of course
but i will say this right now with
without any hesitation at all
no woman
anywhere on earth
should be forced to reproduce absolutely
not
i mean the thought is is
atrocious it's horrifying
the idea that any woman would be forced
to reproduce
the good news is that that's not
happening in america
anywhere
okay
now with abortion
what happens is
you are killing
a human being
who has already been produced
reproduction birth is not reproduction
when a woman gives birth to a child this
is basic biology that i know is lost on
a lot of people these days especially on
the left basic biology
birth
is not the reproductive act
okay reproduction is conception
that is when a separate and distinct
entity with its own dna
comes into existence that is
reproduction this this being this entity
has been produced in that moment
now you can call that uh this being
anything
the correct thing would be human
baby works also person all those work
but you can even use an euphemism like
fetus fetus just means offspring in
latin so sure it's offspring
whatever label you want to put whatever
whatever whatever word you want to use
that being exists and has been produced
in that moment
uh nobody should be forced to conceive
but once conception has happened the
being now exists anything you do after
that is after reproduction it is too
late to prevent the reproduction of that
person
if you are preventing
a an already produced human
from being born
you are not preventing that human being
from being reproduced
any more than if i shoot you in the head
before you walk out your front door in
the morning i haven't stopped you from
being reproduced i have just stopped you
from
changing locations i have stopped you
from emerging from one location into
another location
i've maybe stopped you from becoming
visible to people outside
but i can't shoot you in the head and
say hey man this is my reproductive
rights
uh one other point
real again really basic
if the government
does not have the authority or the right
to pass a law like this
if the state government in texas doesn't
have the authority or the right to pass
a law saying that you can't kill you
cannot kill human beings that have
heartbeats
then government should not exist
there's no argument that i can think of
or that i've ever heard
that would explain you know
why we should have a government at all
and yet not one that will protect the
most innocent and vulnerable among us
like that is the most if if government
has any role
then that would be their most
fundamental and basic
and primary role
to protect the most innocent and
vulnerable
people could not protect themselves
people who
if if the government does not step in
and pass laws protecting them then then
there's then that's it then they'll be
killed
if the government
is not in the business of doing that
then it shouldn't be in the business of
doing anything if it doesn't have
authority and power in in that realm
then i don't see how or why i should
have authority or power in any realm
so god bless uh texas and uh thank god
for all the babies that will now be
granted the
i won't even say will be granted the
gift of life because they're already
living before the abortion happens as we
discussed
but will be granted the gift of
continuing life
the ability to fully you know explore
their own potential as human beings
[Music]
until a judge comes in and blocks the
bill anyway
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content